nodar au bonjour bonjour elisabeth donc
la partie ukrainienne olaf scholz le
chancelier allemand ne ne s'exprime un
mot peut-être de ce qu'il faut attendre
de ce nouveau round de pourparlers
énième round de pourparlers même oui
énième round de pourparlers sauf que
pendant ce temps est bien là la tension
n'a n'arrête pas de monter donc cette
visite du chancelier allemand olaf
scholz et tombe à un moment
particulièrement tendu donc il se rend
d'abord en ukraine il va y avoir une
conférence de presse dans quelques
minutes et demain à moscou certains
disent que c'est un peu la réunion de la
dernière chance pour que cette crise se
termine de manière pacifique là vous
voyez sur la carte que évidemment les
troupes russes sont fortement basée
autour de l'ukraine qu'il s'agisse de la
crimée forte concentration également
près d'une embase au loyer là et puis
tout le long de la frontière de
l'ukraine sans parler bien sûr des des
exercices conjoints qui se déroule en
biélorussie ce qui fait que en fait
notamment alors selon des experts
américains
logistiquement enfin ça y est les
quelques cent ou cent vingt-cinq mille
hommes soldats et armements russes basés
autour de l'ukraine sont prêts
logistiquement pour lancer une invasion
de l'ukraine logistiquement ça veut dire
que mon ami dédé des packs 202 réserve
des hôpitaux militaires de campagne des
stocks de nourriture donc tout il s'agit
tout est prêt il n'y a plus qu'à
attendre si vous voulez le le feu vert
opérationnel et c'est faisable alors on
en est pas encore là mais évidemment
forte tension qui s'est d'ailleurs
traduite notamment sur les marchés
boursiers aux boursiers ce matin que ce
soit côté occidental ou côté russe ou le
rouble a fortement dévissé ce qui veut
dire qu'il ya évidemment une très grande
nervosité
les ukrainiens eux on va en reparler
reste pour le moment calme le président
ukrainien a dit il ne faut pas paniquer
mais on sent clairement des signes de
grande nervosité encore une fois c'était
vocal instant beaucoup de chancelleries
occidentales qui rapatrient leurs
personnels à kiev les américains qui
disent qu'une invasion est possible à
tout moment peut-être même dès mercredi
sans attendre même la fin des jeux
olympiques de pékin donc on est à
nouveau dans une dans une séquence
d'extrême tension en tout cas cette
guerre à l'est de l'europe de plus en
plus réel et concret et en face de cela
on est toujours dans une impasse qui qui
persiste alors évidemment on va voir ce
que donne cette cette conférence de
presse et les échanges de demain mais
les ukrainiens ils réitèrent leur droit
à se tourner vers vers l'otan oui
absolument en fait tout est parti d'une
déclaration peu maladroite de
l'ambassadeur ukrainien à londres ce
week-end qui a dit que sur cette
question de l'adhésion à l'otan
l'ukraine pourrait se montrer flexibles
donc tout de suite on a après on a
interprété cinq hommes voilà le chemin
vers un compromis et ce matin à le
gouvernement ukrainien a remis les
pendules à l'heure en rappelant que
l'adhésion à l'otan est aussi à terme
l'adhésion à l'union européenne étaient
inscrites dans la constitution
ukrainienne et que ça restait un
objectif prioritaire de l'ukraine donc
on voit que là dessus sur la question
d'une adhésion de l'otan à l'ukraine
rien ne bouge finalement puisque la
russie voudrait obtenir une garantie qu
jamais l'ukraine n'ira rejoindre les
rangs de l'otan et côté ukrainien ont
dit bah non nous sommes un pays
souverain nous avons le droit de
rejoindre l'otan donc olaf scholz la
demande à nouveau une désescalade boris
johnson aussi premier ministre
britannique vient de dire qu'il demande
à vladimir poutine de reculer d'un pas
du précipice au bord duquel il se trouve
mais sur le fond du coup rien ne bouge
donc bon match on va faire ce qu'il peut
il va s'exprimer avec le président
ukrainien et demain
ira voir vladimir poutine faisant à peu
près la même tournée diplomatique qu
emmanuel macron la semaine dernière sauf
qu emmanuel macron vais commencer par la
russie puis d'ukraine plats comme le
chancelier scholz commence par l'ukraine
pour marquer quand même que l'ukraine et
du côté des occidentaux et ensuite se
rendra à moscou à noter aussi que
l'ukraine vient de demander une réunion
de l'osce organisation pour la sécurité
et la coopération en europe une enquête
des sceaux dans les années 70 qui était
chargé justement de calmer les
situations de crise et de tensions sur
l'ensemble du comique du continent
européen on la russie n'a pas réagi pour
le moment on verra si ce alors ou alors
ils viennent d'où ils viennent de
rejeter donc ils ne se rendront pas
cette réunion d'urgence convoquée pour
demain et les russes par la voix de
sergueï lavrov qui en attendant que les
ukrainiens et l'allemand ne s'exprime
font savoir que en tout cas sur les les
requêtes sécuritaire formulée par moscou
les réponses pour le moment reçu ne sont
absolument pas satisfaisant juste en un
mot il n'y a aucune avancée selon les
russes d'une part et les ruses dans la
bouche de de sergueï lavrov notamment
commence en fait à inverser la la la la
preuve de la faute je voulais commencer
à dire mais nous ce qu'on observe c'est
des forts mouvements de troupes
ukrainien à la frontière avec la russie
et aussi des mouvements de troupe
ukrainien près de la pseudo frontière
avec la région séparatiste du donbass
donc ce sont les ukrainiens qui ne
montre militairement hostile ils ont
d'ailleurs rappelé ce matin leur droit à
ouvrir le feu sur tout navire ou sous
marin qui violerait l'espace maritime à
ressasser en mer noire et en mer d'azov
notamment la mer d'azov en fait qui
pendant très longtemps été une mère
soviétique a été partagé entre l'ukraine
et la russie par un traité un peu
boiteux en 2003 ou en fait ce sont quand
même les russes qui qui domine donc
s'ils commencent à dire que dès qu'un
navire ukrainien passe six estiment
qu'il est plus ou moins dans les eaux
russes qui ne sont pas vraiment des
limites et va vous voyez qu à tout
moment un dérapage est possible merci
beaucoup bruno daroux